20 manzanas y al menos 170 familias así
se conforma puerta 8 un barrio
desconocido para muchos hasta que la
muerte de decenas de personas tras
consumir drogas adulteradas lo puso en
el centro de atención según las
autoridades gran parte de las víctimas
habría comprado la droga en este lugar
de calles angostas y de construcciones
en ladrillo el barrio es un punto
neurálgico de la venta de
estupefacientes para otras localidades
cercanas tal como lo informó el diario
argentino clarín puerta 8 es uno de los
4.400 16 barrios vulnerables y
asentamientos registrados en el listado
de barrios populares de argentina y se
encuentra en la localidad 3 de febrero
en buenos aires en la zona se tratan los
residuos que genera la capital y
justamente según relata página/12 varias
de las víctimas de la droga adulterada
se dedican a la compraventa de metales y
otros materiales que se encuentran en
los desechos ahora tras las redadas
policiales los habitantes del sector
reclaman justicia y nosotros queremos
con justicia que limpien la casa porque
acá no eran un búnker nada
la carne más consumida que estaba mi
primo solo no más nunca más la que nunca
entra nada nadie nadie y eso lo pusieron
a hacer las cosas
la emergencia sin precedentes en la
historia del país dejó decenas de
personas hospitalizadas algunas se
encuentran en estado crítico me la
dieron ayer que su situación era grave
que había que esperar la evolución como
evolucionada por qué
él estuvo mucho tiempo
dentro con un paro cardíaco
sin respirar y el cerebro sin auxilio al
mismo tiempo en que continúan con las
pesquisas de lo que pudo ocasionar la
intoxicación las autoridades afirman que
podría haber más víctimas en municipios
cercanos